je crois que nos concitoyens ont voulu
exprimer une forme de colère à travers
ces élections départementales même si je
pense que chaque élection doit être
considéré comme étant je dirais un
regard sur une situation particulière là
nous devions nous occuper de ce qui fait
les politiques de proximité les
élections départementales c'est l'action
sociale c'est la gestion des collèges la
gestion des routes pour les assemblées
départementales avec cette nouveauté
puisque nous allons avoir des assemblées
paritaires désormais moi j'en suis très
heureux c'est une défaite pour la gauche
qui nous parvenons à nous maintenir là
où nous étions forts là où nous tenons
des bastions comme on dit fort depuis
longtemps c'est le cas à Cherbourg c'est
le cas aussi dans l'agglomération
cannelle ou nous citons bien et puis
dans l'ordre ou même nous progressons
mais je crois que nous avons un gros
travail à faire notamment sur le milieu
rural où là la gauche en caisse c'est le
mot une défaite assez sévère donc nous
devons travailler sur nos modes de
de réflexion la manière dont nous devons
aujourd'hui accès nos propositions sur
le milieu rural c'est-à-dire les gens
ont montré une réelle inquiétude par
rapport au service public par rapport à
leur vie même quotidienne en milieu
rural et je crois que nous devons
trouver y trouver des réponses et puis
il y a une sanction peut-être une
attente très forte je crois que les gens
sont impatient et c'est bien normal
lorsqu'on en est au chômage on est
impatient qu'il y ait des résultats sur
les politiques économiques et je crois
que le gouvernement a mis un certain
nombre de choses en place mais nous
sommes dans le temps long et ce temps
les Français se tenlont les Français ne
l'acceptent plus ils veulent des
résultats rapides moi je souhaite que
ces résultats puissent venir mais je
souhaite aussi que l'on puisse à un
moment ou un autre s'interroger sur le
bien fondé sur un certain nombre de
choix politiques qui sont faits
notamment en matière économique et je
crois que là aussi nous devons trouver
et nous devons échanger ensemble trouver
des nouvelles passerelles pour discuter
et présenter un projet nous allons
maintenant nous appeler aux élections
régionales c'est un autre mode de
scrutin et là moi je suis un de ceux qui
concurront et à faire en sorte que la
gauche puisse se rassembler sur ces
questions parce qu'on le voit bien
lorsque la gauche elle est unie lorsque
la gauche elle est rassembler et bien la
gauche c'est se maintenir la gauche
s'est proposé je dirais une alternative
totalement crédible et en phase avec ce
que souhaite nos concitoyens dans la
proximité